.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Bewegende Geschichten
sind nicht selten durch
aussergewöhnliche Ereignisse geprägt.
So auch diese.
Zeitlebens war Sepp Epp
ein Bergbauer mit Leib und Seele.
Doch jetzt hindert ihn sein Körper.
Die geliebte Arbeit
ist zur Qual geworden.
Nein, gut wäre anders.
Aber ich arbeite
ab und zu ein bisschen.
Ich versuche zu machen,
was möglich ist.
Aber ... Nein, nein, sonst ...
... habe ich schon etwas Mühe.
Die Familie sucht eine Lösung, damit
es mit dem Hof irgendwie weitergeht.
Man kann noch Tiere haben,
um noch etwas zu haben.
Das hat nichts mehr
mit Landwirtschaft zu tun.
Nein, das ist so,
als hätte man Zwerghasen.
Sepp ist ein Bauer,
wie sein Vater einer war.
Und auch der Grossvater
und der Urgrossvater.
Heute kann der Familienbetrieb
nur dank Mithilfe der Kinder
aufrechterhalten werden.
Der Bergbauer hofft, dass eines
von ihnen den Hof übernehmen wird.
Noch ahnt er nicht,
dass dieser Wunsch zur Zerreissprobe
für die Familie wird.
Dieser Film
spielt vor der grandiosen Kulisse
des Maderanertals im Kanton Uri.
Das Tal zählt zu den wildesten
Gegenden der Schweizer Alpen
und liegt auf der Nordseite
des Gotthardmassivs.
In den Wintermonaten
fällt kein Sonnenstrahl
auf den kleinen Bauernhof.
Ein Schatten scheint sich aber auch
über die Familie gelegt zu haben.
Während der fast 20 Jahren Drehzeit
stellt sie das Leben
immer wieder auf die Probe.
Das Maderanertal,
eine raue Alpenwelt.
Die Naturgewalten
sind nah und spürbar.
Im Winter
führt der Schulweg von Sepps Kindern
Marianne, Silvia und Marcel
mitten durchs Lawinengebiet.
Habt ihr Angst auf dem Schulweg?
Wenn es wirklich viel Schnee hat,
haben wir schon Angst.
Geht ihr dann trotzdem in die Schule?
Ja, Daddy fährt uns viel nach vorne.
Wenn es zu viel Schnee hat,
bleiben wir zu Hause.
Vor Jahren donnerten die Schneemassen
bis ins Wohn-, ja selbst
bis ins Kinderzimmer hinein.
Alles war kaputt.
Die Schränke lagen am Boden,
alles lag verstreut rum.
Sie schmetterte
von dieser Seite durchs Fenster.
Die Wand hier riss es auch um.
Sogar die Tür wurde rausgerissen
und ins Treppenhaus geschleudert.
Januar ist ein Monat,
in dem viele wohl am liebsten
aus dem Weiler verreisen möchten,
der 900 m ü.M. liegt.
Doch die Familie Epp bleibt -
trotz aller Naturgefahren,
die drohen.
Im Februar stürzt
eine gewaltige Lawine auf den Weiler.
Nur gerade
einen Steinwurf vom Hof entfernt
kommen die Schneemassen zum Stehen.
Am Morgen danach:
Die Familie ist wohlauf.
Doch das Acherli
ist von der Umwelt abgeschnitten.
Die Brücke wurde mitgerissen.
Die liegt irgendwo da oben
im Schnee.
Man sieht daran,
was für eine Wucht das hat.
Das sind grosse Massen,
die es weit nach oben schleudert.
Man sieht, dass man als Mensch
keine Chance hätte ...
... zu überleben.
Es ist am besten, wenn man
schon vorher im Haus bleibt.
Aber ja, man weiss wirklich nie,
wann so etwas passieren wird.
In diesen engen Talabschnitt
ziehen 2005 zwei neue Bewohnerinnen.
Die fünfjährige Tamara und Maria Epp.
Kurz danach gibt es Zuwachs:
Maria, die zufälligerweise
den gleichen Nachnamen wie Sepp hat,
kam als Haushälterin.
Ich trennte mich von Tamaras Vater.
Ich ging ein halbes Jahr
nach Schwyz zurück, um zu arbeiten.
Ich habe ein altes Haus hier.
So hat sich das ergeben.
Ich wohnte wieder in Bristen,
als die Stelle hier frei wurde.
So kam ich hierher.
Sie sind aber
etwas mehr als eine Haushälterin.
Ja, jetzt haben wir
zusammen eine Tochter.
Ihr Name ist Julia.
Sie sind schon ein bisschen
eine Patchworkfamilie, oder?
Ja, nicht nur ein bisschen.
Eine richtige Patchworkfamilie.
Ist das in Bristen
noch eine Ausnahme?
Das ist eine grosse Ausnahme.
Ich kenne keine Familie,
die wie wir ist.
An diesem Nachmittag
hat Marcel schulfrei.
Selbstverständlich
hilft er seinem Vater bei der Arbeit.
In seine Fussstapfen möchte
der 13-Jährige aber nicht treten.
Er glaubt, dass man als Bergbauer
bei den Frauen keine Chance habe.
Die meisten denken doch ...
... dass Bauern nur stinken.
Das ist schwierig.
Marcel und seine beiden Schwestern
Marianne und Silvia
wuchsen praktisch
ohne ihre leibliche Mutter auf.
* Lachen *
Schon 1998 verliess seine damalige
Frau ihn und die gemeinsamen Kinder.
Es ging eigentlich relativ schnell.
Sie
ging wieder mal nach Serbien ...
... und als sie zurückkam,
war alles anders.
Sie ging
eigentlich schon am nächsten Tag.
Was genau dahintersteckte,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Aber das war schwierig für Sie.
Sie waren ja alleine mit den Kindern.
Das war sehr schwierig.
Ich habe hier
nicht nur einfache Zeiten erlebt.
Ich habe schon ... Aber ...
Man muss es einfach so nehmen,
wie es kommt.
Man kann nichts erzwingen.
Aber hoffen kann man immer.
* Melancholische Musik *
Nur wenige Male in seinem Leben
hat der Bergbauer das Maderanertal
bisher verlassen.
Eingebettet im steilen Gelände
liegt sein Wiesland.
Ein Fehltritt
könnte fatale Folgen haben.
Zudem
kann es jederzeit Steine hageln.
Was ist mit der Nachbarin passiert?
Das war im ...
... Sommer.
Von hoch oben
stürzten Steine runter.
Sie sah einen Stein kommen
und fokussierte sich auf ihn.
Den zweiten, der dann auf sie fiel,
sah sie darum nicht.
Er sprang ihr in den Unterleib
und sie starb daran.
Sie starb kurz danach.
Im Winter haben sie Lawinen-,
im Sommer Steinschlaggefahr -
für einen Unterländer wie mich
ist es schwierig nachzuvollziehen,
warum Sie hier leben.
Ja ...
Das ist es schon.
Aber ich weiss nicht, wie lange ich
in der Stadt überleben würde.
Wenn ich in den Verkehr müsste.
Das ist halt etwas anderes.
Ja, man lernt von klein auf,
mit den Gefahren umzugehen.
Man soll nicht Angst
vor den Gefahren haben,
aber man soll ihnen immer
mit Achtung begegnen.
Dann geht das schon.
Im Juni ist Alpaufzug.
Es ist ein herrlicher Moment,
wenn man mit ihnen auf die Alp kann.
Das Familienoberhaupt führt den Zug
mit den sieben Kühen an.
So will es die Tradition.
Hinter den Tieren folgt Marcel.
Plötzlich hat Sepp Schmerzen im Knie.
Zum ersten Mal in seinem Leben
übernimmt Marcel die Führung.
Sepp muss dem Alpaufzug
im Auto folgen.
Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht
mit den Kühen marschieren kann.
Es ist so etwas Schönes,
mit den Tieren auf die Alp zu gehen.
Ich muss mich jetzt einfach schonen.
Die Kühe wissen selber
fast besser wohin es geht als ich.
* Zufriedene Musik *
Das Ziel ist die Alp Etzli
unterhalb des Chrüzlipasses
auf 1'350 m ü.M.
Hier verbringen die Kühe
die nächsten drei Monate.
Nehmen wir die Latte längs?
Die Alp
wird als Genossenschaft geführt.
Sepp ist Präsident
der verschworenen Gesellschaft.
Die Bergler leben eng verbunden
mit der Natur und ihrem Glauben.
So darf ich einerseits die Menschen,
die sich während des Alpsommers
um das Vieh kümmern,
aber auch das Vieh segnen.
# Bhüet üs Gott
und dr liaba Jesus Christ.
# Vieh und Alp und alles,
was hie ume isch.
# Bhüet üs Gott vor böser Schtund.
# Es walte Gott
und die liebe Mutter Gottes
# und alle Heiligen.
Hier ist es noch ...
Hier ist es noch grün.
Jetzt kommt die Sonne raus.
Im Juli verbringt Familie Epp
viel Zeit auf ihrem Wiesland,
welches 15 ha umfasst.
- Schön zusammennehmen.
Wunderbar.
Die Kinder haben Schulferien und
packen ohne Murren und Klagen mit an.
Wir sind halt
unglaublich dankbar dafür,
was Daddy für uns gemacht hat.
Er hatte viele schwierige Zeiten
in seinem Leben.
Wir waren immer da
und er kümmerte sich gut um uns.
Darum helfen wir beim Heuen und
müssen ein bisschen darauf achten,
dass wir uns auf ihn abstimmen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
* Lachen und Quietschen *
Im Sommer 2009 zieht Unheil
über dem Acherli auf.
Ein Mordfall, der in der Innerschweiz
viel Aufsehen erregt,
betrifft Familie Epp direkt.
Der Mordprozess findet
im Landratssaal von Altdorf statt.
Bei der mutmasslichen Täterin handelt
es sich um Sepps geschiedene Ehefrau
und Mutter der gemeinsamen Kinder.
Nachdem sie die Familie im Acherli
verlassen hatte,
heiratete sie ein drittes Mal.
Kurz danach soll
sie ihren neuen Ehemann
durch das Spritzen einer Überdosis
Insulin getötet haben.
Handfeste Beweise gibt es keine,
und so kommt es
zu einem Indizienprozess.
Das Obergericht spricht sie schuldig
und verurteilt sie
zu neun Jahren Freiheitsstrafe.
Sepps Ex-Frau
beteuert nach wie vor ihre Unschuld
und reicht Beschwerde
beim Bundesgericht ein.
Wir schauen, wo sie ist.
Marianne, Marcel und Silvia
besuchen ihre Mutter im September.
Sie wurde aus der Haft entlassen,
weil das Bundesgerichtsurteil
noch aussteht.
Hallo, Silvia. Sali, Schatz.
Dragica Epp ist gebürtige Serbin.
Die 44-Jährige
war dreimal verheiratet.
Sie wohnt
bei ihrer Tochter aus erster Ehe,
die auch schon Mutter ist.
Ja, sie malt immer gerne.
Ich bin keine Mörderin.
Ich möchte, dass mein Mann
mit mir aufsteht und weiterlebt.
Die 20 Jahre in der Schweiz
sind die besten meines Lebens.
Ganz ehrlich.
Was bedeutet es dir,
dass deine Mutter hier ist?
Viel.
Meine Schwestern wurden
in der Schule dafür gehänselt,
weil Mami im Gefängnis war.
Aber ich fand immer, dass es nichts
bringe, mit denen zu streiten.
Da wird man nur dümmer.
Anfangs
kam es in der Schule schon vor,
dass
ein blöder Spruch gemacht wurde.
Aber jetzt ist es besser.
Es war auch für uns hart, als wir
sie im Gefängnis besuchen mussten.
Das war hart für die Familie.
Und auch für mich,
wenn ich dort reinmusste.
Man konnte nur kurz
eine Stunde mit ihr sprechen,
dann war sie wieder weg ...
... und man sah sie
eine Weile nicht mehr.
Die gemeinsamen Stunden
könnten gezählt sein:
Sollte auch das Bundesgericht
Dragica Epp schuldig sprechen,
müsste sie zurück ins Gefängnis.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Das Maderanertal an Weihnachten 2009.
Während der Feiertage
erfahren die Kinder der Familie Epp
Neues über ihre Mutter.
(Radiomoderator)
DRS 1, es ist 5.30 Uhr.
Das ist das "Regionaljournal".
(Moderatorin) Das "Regionaljournal
Zentralschweiz" mit diesem Inhalt:
Der Entscheid des Urner Obergerichts
in einem Tötungsfall ist richtig.
Das Bundesgericht stützt
das Urteil des Urner Obergerichts.
Es verurteilte eine Frau
wegen vorsätzlicher Tötung
zu neun Jahren Freiheitsstrafe.
Das Bundesgericht wies
die Beschwerde der Angeklagten
und der Staatsanwaltschaft ab.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich kann nichts dazu sagen.
Das hat mich erschlagen.
Das hat mich ...
Ich hätte das nicht gedacht.
Ja.
Scheisse.
Das hat mich auch erschlagen.
Dass wir das
über das Radio erfahren müssen ...
Es kann ja nicht sein,
dass die, die dahinterstecken -
wer auch immer das ist -,
das nicht zuerst
den Angehörigen sagen,
sondern zuerst dem Radio
und allen möglichen Medien.
Das finde ich scheisse.
- Ich habe das Gefühl,
sie haben gar nicht darauf geachtet,
dass sie Kinder hat.
Dass wir auch noch da sind.
Sie ist nur die Böse
und wir müssen damit leben.
Wartet ihr schon?
Herr Epp,
es kam gerade die Nachricht,
dass Ihre Ex-Frau vom Bundesgericht
verurteilt wurde.
Was denken Sie dazu?
Ja ... Also, ich ...
Wenn sie es gemacht hat -
meinetwegen.
Mir tun die Kinder leid.
Sie sind in diesem Schlamassel
die Leidtragenden.
Sie tun mir wirklich leid.
Sie müssen arbeiten und machen
und ja ...
... auch noch damit fertigwerden.
Das wird ein Problem.
Schicksalsschläge
musste er schon einige verkraften.
Er nahm sie hin, ohne zu klagen.
Sepp findet seinen Frieden
bei der Arbeit mit den Tieren.
Viel verdient er damit nicht.
Also, keine 20'000 Fr.
Pro Jahr?
- Pro Jahr.
Wenn ich ...
Wie kommt man damit durch?
Ja ...
Man muss sich natürlich
schon stark einschränken.
So gut das halt geht.
Man kann nicht immer in den Ausgang.
Aber das ist auch nicht nötig.
Ein Jahresbudget von netto 20'000 Fr.
geht nur dank Selbstversorgung.
(Alle) # Stille Nacht ...
# ... heilige Nacht.
# Gottes Sohn ...
# ... oh wie lacht ...
# ... Lieb
aus deinem göttlichen Mund.
# Da uns schlägt die rettende Stund.
Nur Julia, die Kleinste,
bekommt ein Geschenk:
Farbstifte,
eine Stoffpuppe und ein Malbuch.
Mehr liegt nicht drin.
Ein Malbuch.
Ich sage meinen Kindern immer,
dass ich im Sommer
eher mal etwas schenke.
Oder wenn sie etwas haben müssen.
Anstatt zu Weihnachten
etwas zu schenken,
wenn es vielleicht
nicht so dringend ist.
* Ruhige Musik *
Das Mähen fällt ihm zunehmend schwer.
Die Hüfte schmerzt, aber auch seine
Knie- und Fussgelenke plagen ihn.
Nur dank Schmerzmitteln
kann er noch arbeiten.
Ich habe
schon ein bisschen Probleme,
aber jetzt ist das Wetter schön.
Jetzt darf man
nicht einmal daran denken.
Was heisst "ein bisschen Probleme"?
Wurde es schlimmer?
Ja,
es wird schon immer etwas schlimmer.
In diesem Sommer schwingt der
Bergbauer zum letzten Mal die Sense.
Bald wird er erfahren, dass seine
Gelenke aufgrund der schweren Arbeit
massiv abgenutzt sind.
* Betrübte Musik *
Den Oktober
verbringt er im Spital Liestal.
Beide Sprunggelenke wurden versteift.
Der Arzt sagte ...
... so einen kaputten Knochen
habe er noch selten gesehen.
Ja, von der Abnutzung her.
Ich habe sicher
gewisse Zukunftsängste.
Ich meine, wenn man so eine
Operation an beiden Beinen hat ...
... hat man sicher Zukunftsängste.
Aber ja, nach vorne schauen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Während der Bergbauer
im Spital liegt,
bleibt viel Arbeit an seiner
Lebenspartnerin Maria Epp hängen.
Sepp sagt ihr zwar am Telefon,
was es zu tun gibt,
aber seine Zukunftsängste
behält er für sich.
Das weiss ich nicht.
Er ist einer ...
Entweder geht es oder es geht nicht.
Bei einer solchen Operation
an den Fussgelenken
kann man nur abwarten und schauen,
wie der Heilungsprozess verläuft.
Dann werden wir es wissen.
Die vielen Sorgen
wachsen Maria über den Kopf.
Sie zieht sich ab diesem Moment
von den Dreharbeiten zurück.
Nur noch in seltenen Fällen
lässt sie sich filmen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Einmal mehr
war der Bergbauer im Spital.
Hallo.
Frisch operiert
kehrt er nach Hause zurück.
Alles gut, Sepp?
- Ja, ja.
Daddy, hallo.
- Hallo.
Du kleiner Wurm.
Hallo, Julia.
Zu den bereits
früher versteiften Sprunggelenken
erhielt er auch noch Prothesen
an beiden Knien.
Zudem wurde ihm ein künstliches
Hüftgelenk eingesetzt.
Hey.
Daddy ist wieder hier.
Ja. Und jetzt?
Hey. Hm?
Während seiner Abwesenheit
regnete es oft im Maderanertal.
Die Grasernte fiel mager aus.
Nun fehlt es
an Heuvorrat für den Winter.
Sepp braucht zusätzliches Futter
für die Tiere.
Für das nötige Geld
muss er eine Kuh verkaufen.
Was willst du für die?
Die ist fast unverkäuflich.
Hä?
Es ist immer so,
wenn man ein Tier im Stall hat,
das man nicht verkaufen will.
Du hast ja noch ein paar Gute.
Wieso wollen Sie
diese Kuh nicht verkaufen?
Macht man Aufzucht, sollte man
die Besten nicht verkaufen.
Aber der Handel ist so schlecht,
dass man die verkaufen sollte,
die gefragt sind.
Das ist das Problem.
Dann hat man einfach
ein paar Franken, aber ...
Ich nehme die dort hinten.
Andermau.
- Ja.
3'000 Fr.
- Gut.
Ein halbes Jahr ist seit seinem
letzten Spitalaufenthalt vergangen.
Noch immer schmerzt jeder Schritt.
Er ist nicht mehr der Bergbauer,
der er einmal war.
Sepp kann seiner geliebten Arbeit
nicht mehr wie gewohnt nachgehen.
Schweren Herzens
entschliesst er sich,
ein paar weitere Tiere zu verkaufen.
Das ist ein sehr schwieriger Moment.
Es könnte der Anfang des Endes
des Betriebs im Acherli sein.
Tschüss.
Der Bergbauer will die Hoffnung
aber nicht aufgeben.
Würde eines seiner Kinder
den Hof übernehmen,
könnte der Familienbetrieb
weitergeführt werden.
* Lautes Muhen *
* Entspannte Musik *
Im Zürcher Hotel Leoneck
arbeitet seit Kurzem eine junge Frau
aus dem Maderanertal.
Grüezi. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
- Grüss Gott.
Ich würde gerne einchecken.
- Gerne.
Marianne
ist als Rezeptionistin angestellt.
Parallel dazu
besucht sie die Hotelfachschule.
Das Leben in der Stadt ist mit
vielen neuen Eindrücken verbunden.
Mir ist am meisten aufgefallen,
dass die Gäste wenig Zeit haben.
Im Kanton Uri nehmen es die Leute
etwas gemütlicher.
V.a. im Oberland.
Die Zeit
ist hier für alles eher knapp.
Hier ist der Schlüssel.
Ihr Herz
hat sie nicht an Zürich verschenkt.
Mariannes Heimat
bleibt das Acherli im Maderanertal.
Danke.
In meiner Freizeit gehe ich
sicher immer nach Bristen.
Im Sommer sowieso, wenn es
so heiss ist und sie am Heuen sind.
Ich habe fast ein schlechtes
Gewissen, wenn ich hier bin.
Ein paar Wochen später.
Im Mai 2015
in der Zürcher Hotelfachschule
Belvoirpark.
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren,
ich sehe
nur fröhlich strahlende Gesichter.
Das gehört sich natürlich auch, wenn
Sie in ein paar wenigen Augenblicken
Ihr wirklich verdientes Diplom
entgegennehmen dürfen.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen ganz,
ganz herzlich zu Ihrem Diplom.
Das Strahlen in Ihrem Gesicht
ist eindeutig: Sie freuen sich auch.
Alles Gute.
Schön, dass Sie hier sind.
Marianne Epp hat die Hotelfachschule
nach drei Jahren Ausbildung
erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
In den Anfangsjahren in der Schule
hätte ich mich nie getraut zu sagen,
dass sie so einen Beruf lernen kann.
Das hätte ich nie gewagt.
Ich habe etwas geschafft,
von dem viele sagten,
dass die Kinder aus dem Acherli
das nie erreichen würden.
Das ist ein gutes Gefühl.
Ich habe etwas erreicht,
von dem alle immer sagten,
dass ich es nicht schaffen werde.
Dass ich
nie etwas Gutes erreichen werde.
Das ist eine Erleichterung.
Ich habe etwas gemacht
und habe es durchgezogen.
Ich hatte den Willen,
das zu schaffen.
Ich bin megaglücklich.
Ich kann gar nicht ausdrücken,
wie sehr ich mich freue.
Bestanden.
Während Marianne im Hotel arbeitet,
beginnt ihr Bruder Marcel Epp
im Sommer 2015
eine Lehre als Lastwagenchauffeur.
Noch fehlt ihm der Fahrausweis.
Deshalb ist er meistens in der
Werkstatt des Transportunternehmens
anzutreffen.
Das gefällt mir
eigentlich wunderbar.
Der Job
wird einfach brutal unterschätzt.
Ich dachte anfangs auch immer,
dass ein Chauffeur halt
den ganzen Tag im Lastwagen sitzt
und seine Runden dreht.
Als ich mit meinem Ausbildner
fahren ging, merkte ich,
dass man abends körperlich
noch ganz fit ist,
aber geistig ist man müde.
Die Belastung auf der Strasse
sollte man nicht unterschätzen.
Aber es gefällt mir.
Ich möchte wirklich
nichts anderes mehr machen.
Er wohnt nach wie vor
bei seinem Vater.
In seine Fussstapfen treten
möchte Marcel nicht.
Aber der 19-Jährige packt in jeder
freien Minute auf dem Hof mit an.
Ob ich will oder nicht, ich muss.
Ich hatte Anfang Juli
und Anfang August eine Woche Ferien
und habe die Zeit
mehr oder weniger dazu genutzt,
meinem Vater beim Heuen zu helfen.
Der Sommer geht dem Ende entgegen.
Die Bauern
der Genossenschaft von Bristen
treiben ihre Tiere von der Alp
zurück in die Ställe.
Den Alpabzug
sitzend am Steuer mitzuerleben,
ist für den 63-Jährigen
schon fast zur Gewohnheit geworden.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mit seinen versteiften Knöcheln
und künstlichen Gelenken
kann er nur noch kurze Strecken
zu Fuss gehen.
An einer Weggabelung werden die Tiere
auf die einzelnen Höfe aufgeteilt.
Hier trifft er auf die anderen Bauern
und auch auf Silvia und Tamara.
Dann könnt ihr gleich loslaufen.
Bist du nicht fit?
Ich habe wieder Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe schon daran gedacht,
mal wieder nach oben zu kommen.
Aber ich komme nicht mehr runter.
Ich habe immer
ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen.
Es tut einfach alles weh.
Ja, irgendwann sowieso, oder?
Ja, wenn du 50 wirst
und nichts wehtut,
musst du davon ausgehen,
dass du tot bist.- Ja, richtig.
Da ist was dran.
Es ist nicht jeden Tag gleich.
Ja.
Also, Sepp, alles Gute.
- Ja, gleichfalls.
Achte gut auf dich.
- Eine gute Zeit.
Fühlen Sie sich etwas abseits,
wenn Sie nicht
wie früher mitmachen können?
Ja, das ist schon ...
... das,
was mich am stärksten mitnimmt.
Dass ich nicht mehr mitgehen kann.
Das machte ich immer gerne.
Auch auf der Alp zu arbeiten ...
Man musste mich nie
zweimal darum bitten.
Aber jetzt ist einfach fertig.
Wenn man nicht mehr arbeiten kann,
ist man nichts mehr wert.
Wie es mit dem Familienbetrieb
weitergehen soll,
wird zur zentralen Frage.
Tamara ist mit ihren 14 Jahren
noch zu jung dazu.
Silvia hat eine Ausbildung
als Pflegefachfrau abgeschlossen.
Momentan
ist die 20-Jährige auf Stellensuche.
Im Acherli sieht sie für sich
keine grosse Zukunft.
Grundsätzlich mag ich das Vieh
und die Landwirtschaft.
Aber wenn man hier oben alleine ist,
hat man schon verloren.
Da muss man gar nicht anfangen.
Man braucht einen Partner,
der voll mitzieht.
Sonst geht es nicht.
Bald hat Tamara die obligatorische
Schulzeit hinter sich.
Langsam muss sie sich mit
der Berufswahl auseinandersetzen.
Köchin gefällt mir ziemlich gut.
Und Bäuerin?
- Eher nicht.
Nicht?
- Nein.
Der Bergbauer
sieht sein Lebenswerk bedroht.
Es ist etwas schade,
dass man so viel investiert hat
und am Schluss
dann niemand mehr hier ist.
Hand aufs Herz: Tut es Ihnen weh?
Es tut mir schon ein bisschen weh -
auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube,
jeder Bauer wünscht sich ...
... wenn er pensioniert wird,
dass jemand Junges hier ist
und man noch etwas helfen könnte.
Das wäre das Schönste.
Aber wenn niemand mehr
Landwirtschaft betreibt,
kann man nicht helfen.
Und alleine ist es fertig.
Ja.
Bevor Sepp den Acherli-Hof übernahm,
war seine Mutter Katharina Epp
hier Bäuerin gewesen.
Seit vier Generationen
ist der Hof in Familienbesitz.
Die Grossen gehen ja nach Bodmi,
oder?- Mhm.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Strafanstalt Hindelbank
im Kanton Bern.
Dragica Epp, die Mutter
von Marianne, Silvia und Marcel,
wird entlassen.
Von ihren neun Jahren Haftstrasse
musste sie sechs absitzen.
Marcel. Mamis Sohn.
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, mein lieber Sohn.
- Morgen, Schatzi.
Geht es dir gut?
- Doch, doch.- Schön.
Marcel, Mausi, ist dir kalt?
- Es ist kalt.
Komm.
- Geht es dir gut?
Ja, Marcel-Maus.
- Schön.
Ich freue mich sehr
auf meine Familie, auf meinen Sohn.
Ich warte schon lange
auf diese Freude.
Jetzt ist der Tag da.
Es war nicht einfach,
aber sie hat es geschafft.
Sie kann das Kapitel abschliessen.
Es ist schon schön,
unsere Mutter in der Nähe zu haben.
Die Familie ist wieder zusammen.
Dragica Epp
hat laut Bundesgerichtsurteil
ihren dritten Ehemann
durch eine Überdosis Insulin getötet.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen,
ob sie es gemacht hat.
Hat sie es gemacht, ist es so.
Und sonst ist auch gut.
Sie wurde ja bestraft
mit diesen sechs Jahren hier.
Wenn sie das gemacht hat, hoffe ich,
dass sie etwas gelernt hat.
Dass sie gemerkt hat,
dass sie einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Aber nein, ich glaube nicht,
dass sie es getan hat.
Nein.
Im Untergeschoss
eines Hauses im Kanton Uri
bezieht Dragica Epp
eine Sozialwohnung.
Die Kinder haben die Möbel organi-
siert und die Wohnung eingerichtet.
Bist du zufrieden mit den Möbeln?
- Ja schon. Mit der Wohnung nicht.
Weisst du, woher wir sie haben?
Aus Luzern.
- Ja. Aber ...
Was?
- ... die Wohnung ist ...
... nicht so toll für mich.
- Warum?
Sie ist schön, aber mein Asthma ...
Es ist nicht so übel.
- Nein, nein.
Sei zufrieden.
Aber im Moment
ist sie sehr gut für mich.
Ich brauche ...
Der Neuanfang
erfüllt die 50-Jährige mit Sorgen.
Ich liebe dieses Land.
Ich liebe die Schweiz.
Ich bin keine Mörderin.
So bin ich wirklich nicht.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Es tut mir weh,
dass man das mit mir gemacht hat.
Ich bin wirklich keine Mörderin.
Du musst keine Angst haben, dass sie
auf der Strasse auf dich zeigen.
Davor musst du keine Angst haben.
- Das ist furchtbar.
Das machen sie ja nicht.
Keine Angst.
Das ist ein Schmerz ...
- Das kommt schon gut.
* Ruhige Musik *
Sepp muss sich erholen.
Eine starke Grippe
machte ihn zum medizinischen Notfall.
Plötzlich legte es mich um.
Ich musste ins Spital,
sonst hätte ich ...
Ich konnte nicht mehr atmen, nicht
mehr gehen, nicht mehr arbeiten.
Es gab keine andere Option.
Sohn Marcel
hat extra Ferien genommen,
um das Vieh zu versorgen.
Mein Husten ...
- ... wird nicht besser.
... braucht Ewigkeiten,
um zu heilen.
Sein Vater hat wieder
ein paar Tiere dazugekauft.
Im Stall müssen jetzt acht Kühe
und acht Rinder versorgt werden.
Marcel unterstützt seinen Vater
mit gemischten Gefühlen.
Es gibt Tage, an denen ich sage:
"Warum muss ich jetzt wieder?"
"Die anderen müssen ja auch nicht."
Aber ja,
er hat immer alles für uns gemacht.
Auch jetzt noch.
Ich bin noch in der Lehre
und habe noch nicht viel Geld.
Wenn ich Pneus oder einen Service
für mein Auto brauche,
hilft er mir, damit alles stimmt.
Es ist also nur gerecht,
wenn auch die Jungen etwas machen.
So, jetzt dann gleich.
Jetzt dann gleich.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Pfeifen *
Hey da.
Stefan Roos ist ein 25-jähriger Bauer
im luzernischen Ruswil.
Er hat 20 Kühe
und lebt von der Milchwirtschaft.
Via Facebook lernte er vor einem Jahr
eine 23-jährige Frau
aus dem Kanton Uri kennen.
Seit ein paar Monaten leben
die beiden gemeinsam auf dem Hof
unweit des Sempachersees.
Hast du ihn?
- Ja.
Seine Herzdame ist Silvia Epp.
Einer ist da drüben.
Gerade musste sie ihre Hüfte
aufgrund einer Fehlbildung operieren.
Auf dem Hof mitzuhelfen
ist ihr deshalb nicht möglich.
Stefan ist das egal.
Der Bauer ist einfach froh,
sein Glück gefunden zu haben.
Als ich sie zum ersten Mal sah,
wusste ich:
"Das ist die Richtige."
- Wirklich?
Ja.
- Die grosse Liebe?- Ja.
Es war
fast Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Bei dir auch, Silvia?
Ich bin da
eher etwas anders veranlagt.
Bei mir ist das nicht so einfach.
Sympathie war da.
Alles andere muss man aufbauen.
Silvia würde gerne
wieder als Pflegefachfrau arbeiten,
aber ihre Gesundheit
lässt das momentan nicht zu.
Dafür brachte sie bereits
neuen Schwung in den Betrieb.
Sie eröffnete einen kleinen Hofladen.
Läuft der Laden bis jetzt?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Wir sind nicht im Dorfzentrum.
Viele Leute wissen gar nicht,
dass es den Laden gibt.
Auch wenn wir es signalisieren.
Es ist einen Versuch wert.
Wenn ich in einem Jahr merke,
dass es gar nicht läuft,
kann ich es wieder zusammenräumen.
Stefan hat den Hof
von seinen Eltern gepachtet.
Den Vater sieht er nicht oft.
Das Verhältnis zu ihm ist angespannt.
Silvia ist noch nicht ganz
in ihrem neuen Leben angekommen.
Vermisst du das Acherli?
Ja, schon.
Wir gehen viel hin.
Wir haben einen guten Draht zu mei-
nem Vater und meinen Geschwistern.
Aber manchmal denke ich schon ...
Ich bin halt
nicht hier aufgewachsen.
Ich bin schon noch
im Acherli zu Hause.
Im Acherli,
bei Sepp und seiner Familie,
fühlt sich auch Stefan sehr wohl.
Dass der Bergbauer den Hof
an die nächste Generation
übergeben will, weiss auch er.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
das Acherli zu übernehmen?
Nein, das kann ich nicht.
Ich wäre nicht der Typ dafür.
Denke ich.
- Wenn wir zusammenbleiben,
schauen wir,
wie wir das hier managen.
Ich werde meinen Beruf
trotzdem noch ausüben.
Von der Landwirtschaft
könnten wir nicht leben.
Ja.
(Dragica) Nicht mit der Schaufel.
Dragica Epp gibt ein Abschiedsfest.
Die Mutter
von Marianne, Silvia und Marcel
verlässt die Schweiz.
Sie zieht zu ihrem neuen
Lebenspartner in den Balkan.
* Serbisch *
Das ist mein Mann.
Wo ist er jetzt?
Das ist meine Wohnung dort.
Das Zimmer meiner Schwägerin
und die Küche.
In Montenegro?
- Genau.
Auch Marcel kommt,
um seine Mutter zu verabschieden.
Sie wird ihn sowie die anderen Kinder
und Enkelkinder aus erster Ehe
nicht mehr häufig sehen.
Das tut mir weh. Es tut mir
für meine ganze Familie weh.
Aber ich kann nichts anderes machen.
Ich bin ...
- Du könntest ja hierbleiben.
Nein, Silvia, Schatzi ...
- Drei Monate hier, drei dort ...
Nein, ich habe kein Leben mehr.
Mein Leben ist total kaputt,
Schatzi.
Ich mag wirklich nicht mehr.
Sie lebt nicht mehr in der Schweiz,
aber sie ist ja nicht ab der Welt.
Wenn es das Beste für sie ist,
soll sie das machen.
Ich finde, dass man es
nirgends besser als hier hat.
Aber wenn sie das will,
lassen wir sie gehen.
Danke.
- Ich habe dich lieb.
So, du kannst ein Foto machen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Bei Silvia und Stefan
kündigen sich Veränderungen an.
Sie ist im dritten Monat schwanger.
Wurdest du überraschend schwanger
oder war es gewollt?
Schon eher überraschend.
Aber nicht weniger gewollt.
Weisst du, ob es
ein Mädchen oder einen Jungen gibt?
Nein, noch nicht.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
ob ich es wissen will.
Es ist eigentlich egal.
Nach zwei Fehlgeburten ist man
zufrieden mit einem gesunden Kind.
Trotz zweier Fehlgeburten
ist die 23-Jährige zuversichtlich,
dass diesmal
alles gut verlaufen wird.
Die Vorfreude auf das Kind
wird allerdings getrübt:
Die Finanzen des Hofes
liegen in Schieflage.
Ja, Existenzängste ...
... sind schon da.
Abends nach getaner Arbeit
macht man sich etwas Gedanken.
Ich frage mich auch:
Kriege ich alles hin?
Was muss ich machen?
Wie ist es, wenn das Kind da ist?
Ja ...
Belasten die Existenzängste
auch die Beziehung?
Ja, sowieso.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wir hatten schon
intensive Gespräche darüber.
Schaffen wir das?
Wie sehen wir die Zukunft?
Ja ...
V.a., weil ich ganz andere Vor-
stellungen und Ideale habe als er.
Wir müssen immer
einen Mittelweg finden.
Ich habe so viel von Daddy gelernt
und übernommen -
das nimmt man automatisch mit.
Und wenn man mit einem Partner
einen Betrieb managt,
hat man das Gefühl,
es sollte auch so laufen.
Dann will er es aber
manchmal anders machen.
Ja.
Vieles läuft nicht so wie gewünscht.
Beim Gehen schmerzt
die operierte Hüfte noch immer.
Auch eine Stelle
hat Silvia noch nicht gefunden.
Zudem bleibt die Kundschaft
im Hofladen weiterhin aus.
Ist das nicht enttäuschend?
Du kamst
aus dem Maderanertal runter
und dachtest, das sei besserer Boden
und ein anderer Hof,
aber du hast fast dieselben
Existenzkämpfe wie oben.
Ja. Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Am Anfang.
Wenn man so frisch verliebt ist,
sieht man das alles noch nicht.
Es ging ein halbes Jahr,
bis ich verstand, wie es hier läuft.
Ich konnte viel von Daddy lernen.
Wir räumen gerade stark auf
und strukturieren um.
Wir machen und tun.
* Sanfte Musik *
Marianne verbringt diesen Sommer
jede freie Minute
im Weiler Acherli
oberhalb von Bristen.
Die 27-Jährige führt den Hof
ihres Vaters praktisch im Alleingang.
Und das
nebst ihrem 100-%-Job im Gastgewerbe.
Ich hatte kaum
so einen strengen Sommer wie diesen.
Ich war am Anschlag.
Ich versuchte so viel zu machen,
wie ich konnte.
Ich habe das auch für mich gemacht.
Wäre es weg, würde es mir fehlen.
Das wäre auch schade.
Also dachte ich:
"Beiss die Zähne zusammen."
"Es gibt wieder andere Zeiten."
Irgendeine Lösung kommt sicher.
Die Vorfreude auf das Kind
will Silvia mit ihrem Vater teilen.
Sepp wird zum ersten Mal Grossvater.
Er nimmt es gelassen.
Das sei der Lauf des Lebens.
Das ist alles menschlich.
Das ist auch richtig.
Ich wollte auch Kinder haben.
Wenn sie Kinder wollen,
sollen sie Kinder haben.
Das ist nur recht so.
Wir wussten immer, dass wir
keine Angst vor dir haben müssen.
Auch wenn wir mit 16, 18 oder 20
schwanger geworden wären.
Das wäre nie ein Problem gewesen.
- Nein. Das ist eigentlich ...
Das ist schön.
Das können nicht alle sagen.
Das ist so.
Er wäre nicht böse gewesen.
Die Hauptsache war immer,
dass ihr arbeitet.
Dann war es kein Problem.
Wenn wir uns
nicht gegenseitig geholfen hätten,
hätte es die letzten zwei Jahre
nicht geklappt.
Nein. Nein.
Es halfen immer alle mit.
Hätten wir nicht zusammengearbeitet,
hätte es nicht mehr funktioniert.
Hast du kein schlechtes Gewissen,
dass das nur klappt,
wenn die Kinder immer wieder helfen?
Ja ... Also, doch.
Irgendwann hat man
schon ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Aber es ist halt immer wieder schön,
wenn die Kinder mir helfen.
Wenn sie nicht mehr helfen könnten,
kämen sie gar nicht mehr.
Ja, also gut ... Nein, nein.
Für mich wäre es seltsam,
wenn wir aufhören würden.
Ich hänge halt an den Tieren.
- Ja.
Das wissen wir.
- (Silvia) Das geht uns auch so.
Das geht uns genau gleich.
- Einfach ...
Ungefähr. Ja, ja.
- Damit wir etwa wissen ...
Das Transportunternehmen Baldini
in Altdorf.
Ich öffne das Tor und du kannst den
Lastwagen auf den Parkplatz stellen.
Ja.- Dann schliesst du ab
und bringst mir den Schlüssel.
Ist gut?
- Tipptopp.- Gut.
Tamara Epp ist im zweiten Lehrjahr
als Lastwagenfahrerin.
Noch darf sie
nur auf dem Gelände der Firma fahren.
Bist du immer noch nervös,
wenn du fährst?
Beim ersten Mal war ich sehr nervös.
Aber langsam klappt es.
Ursprünglich
wollte Tamara eine Kochlehre machen.
Nun habe sie ihren Traumberuf
gefunden, sagt die 18-Jährige.
Mein Ziel ist,
die Lehre zu machen und zu arbeiten.
So.
Aber nicht als Bäuerin im Acherli.
- Nein, lieber nicht.
Es wäre schade, wenn es
den Bauernhof nicht mehr gäbe,
aber
es ist wirklich streng und mühsam.
* Ruhige Musik *
Seit Tamara in der Lehre ist,
lebt sie in Altdorf.
Hallo.
- Hallo.- Hallo.
Zusammen mit Marcel
gründete sie eine WG.
Er hat seine Lehre inzwischen
erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
Wo ist dein Zimmer?
- Direkt hier.
Ich habe verschiedene Bilder
als Erinnerungen.
Hier habe ich ein Bild
von Mami, Daddy und mir.
Eines mit meiner Grossmutter
und der Firmpatin bei der Firmung.
Hier noch mit Marianne ...
Familienbilder halt.
Hast du Heimweh nach dem Acherli?
- Manchmal schon.
Aber ich bin schon ein Jahr hier
und habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Und?
Heute ist Silvia zu Besuch.
Eigentlich
wäre es Zeit für das Abendessen.
Kochst du heute?
- Nein. Hättest du gerne.
Ah ja, abgesehen vom Weihnachtsessen
kannst du nichts.
Wir müssen noch
wegen der Karte schauen.
Das sage ich seit einem Monat.
- Das sage  i c h  seit einem Monat.
Ich weiss nicht wohin.
- Ich habe dir die Adresse gegeben.
Du brauchst
nur noch einen Briefkasten.
Wie funktioniert eure WG,
Tamara und Marcel?
Manchmal besser,
manchmal schlechter. Je nachdem.
Es ist halt eine WG.
- Was heisst das?
Manchmal könnten wir uns köpfen,
manchmal nicht.
Warum denn, Marcel?
Es sind immer etwa dieselben Dinge.
Z.B. die Wäsche: Wer wäscht?
Oder man lässt etwas stehen,
die andere Person kommt nach Hause
und denkt:
"Schon wieder nicht aufgeräumt."
Oder: "Der Abfallsack
wurde wieder nicht entsorgt."
Aber zu Hause ist es auch so.
Da ist nicht immer
Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Daher ist das ertragbar.
Warum sieht man dich
nicht mehr oft im Acherli oben?
Ja, nicht mehr so viel ...
Ich wohne schon länger
nicht mehr dort.
Ich habe mein Leben.
Ich habe eine 100-%-Stelle,
die ich gut machen muss.
Im Sommer habe ich schon viel Arbeit
und bin die ganze Zeit unterwegs.
Dann komme ich am Freitagabend
oder Samstagmorgen nach Hause.
Man kann nicht erwarten,
dass ich dann noch arbeite.
Irgendwann
muss man auch regenerieren.
* Ein Baby schreit. *
Dana.
- Scheint so.
Gut, alle schön lachen.
Der 28. Dezember.
Für Silvia und Stefan
ein bedeutender Tag.
Soeben
gaben sich die beiden
auf dem Standesamt
im luzernischen Wolhusen das Ja-Wort.
Gut. Super, danke.
Wie fühlst du dich jetzt?
- Ja, gut.
Ein neuer Lebensabschnitt.
- Heisst du noch Epp?
Ja, ich behalte meinen Namen.
Er nimmt meinen Namen an.
* Sanfte Musik *
Silvia ist im achten Monat schwanger.
Jetzt ist es wach.
Hast du es gemerkt? Es boxt.
- Ja.
Es war immer klar,
dass wir heiraten
und das klassische Familienbild
leben wollen.
Mit dem Kind
wurde das noch zentraler.
Wir wollen miteinander agieren.
Ja.
Darum
entschieden wir uns zu dem Schritt.
In ein bis zwei Jahren
war das sowieso geplant.
Es hat sich einfach vorverschoben.
Aber das war immer
ein Herzenswunsch.
Die Sorgen des Alltags
sind an diesem Tag weit weg.
Was ist dein grösster Wunsch
für die nähere Zukunft?
Eine Familie mit Silvia zu haben.
Füreinander da zu sein.
Und weiterhin einen guten Draht
zur Familie Epp zu haben.
Ich freue mich sehr auf die Zeit.
Es wird sicher
viele schöne Momente geben.
Ein Kind
ist schon etwas Einzigartiges.
Das ist ein Glück,
das man nicht kaufen kann.
Sepp, der normalerweise allen Ver-
änderungen gelassen gegenübersteht,
geht die Heirat seiner Tochter nahe.
Wie hast du
den Moment der Trauung erlebt?
Ja, es war schön und feierlich.
Also, ja ...
Aber hat es dich bewegt?
- Ja, also ... Ja.
Es hat mich wirklich ...
Es habe Tränen bei dir gegeben.
- Ja.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe schon wieder ...
... eine Tochter weniger.
Ja. Sie wird schon
ab und zu nach Hause kommen,
aber man muss damit rechnen,
dass man ein Kind weniger hat.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Alp Pesciüm oberhalb von Airolo.
Marianne
hat ihre Stelle in Zürich aufgegeben
und ist wieder in die Berge gezogen.
Sie
arbeitet nach wie vor im Gastgewerbe.
Aber eigentlich schlägt ihr Herz
für die Landwirtschaft.
Ein Dilemma.
Grazie.
- Prego.
Ich bin wirklich
hin- und hergerissen.
Eigentlich habe ich
die Hotelfachschule gemacht
und könnte locker
gut Geld verdienen.
Aber trotzdem kann ich
zu Hause nicht loslassen ...
... und alles hinwerfen.
Mein Traum ist, das zu verbinden.
Gastronomie und Landwirtschaft
zusammenzubringen.
Aber wie ich das mache,
weiss ich noch nicht.
Ja.
Das landwirtschaftliche Bildungs-
zentrum im urnerischen Seedorf.
Weitere Rassen? Marianne,
kennst du eine?- Charolais?
Wie sieht die aus?
- Weiss.- Weiss.
Schon gesehen im Kanton Uri?
- Nein.
Woher kennst du sie?
- Aus Frankreich, glaube ich.- Ja.
Die Hotelfachschule
hat sie schon absolviert.
Nun besucht Marianne
auch noch die Bauernschule.
Ich mache mal die Bauernschule.
Was danach passiert, ob ich
Landwirtschaft betreibe oder nicht,
ist dann Nebensache.
Aber es
ist eine gute Grundausbildung.
Ich kann immer noch
in meinem Job arbeiten.
Das ist nicht so eine Sache.
Du hast also vor,
den Hof im Acherli zu übernehmen?
Ja. Jein.
Das weiss ich noch nicht so richtig.
Das ist
noch eine verwirrte Situation.
Ich habe
einen sehr guten Job in Airolo.
Den Hof noch dazu zu übernehmen,
wäre fast etwas viel für mich.
Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre.
Vielleicht hat sich
die Situation bis dann geklärt.
Mit etwas Unterstützung könne sie
dann das Acherli übernehmen.
Zudem spielt sie mit der Idee, dort
auch einen Gastbetrieb zu eröffnen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Fertig geschlafen?
Seit dem 2. Februar 2019
ist Luisa auf der Welt.
So heisst die Tochter
von Silvia und Stefan Epp.
Doch jetzt, Anfang März,
liegt das Baby
schwer krank im Kinderspital Luzern.
Sie hat sich
mit Keuchhusten angesteckt.
Sie lief blau an
und atmete einen Moment nicht mehr.
Ich ging dann
sofort mit ihr ins Spital.
Sie klärten das dann sofort ab.
Was sagen die Ärzte?
Dass es eine lange Geschichte wird.
Es nimmt einen schon mit.
Es ist mein eigenes Kind.
Das nimmt einen mit.
V.a., weil es bei so kleinen Kindern
schwer verlaufen kann.
Man hofft einfach,
dass sie wieder ganz gesund wird.
Haben wenigstens die Sorgen
auf dem Hof etwas nachgelassen?
Nicht wirklich, nein. Aber ja ...
Das hat momentan keine Priorität.
Während Silvia die ganze Zeit
im Spital bei Luisa bleibt,
schaut Stefan einmal pro Tag vorbei.
Hoi.
- Hoi. Wie geht's?
Die Sorgen um seinen Hof und
jetzt die Krankheit seiner Tochter
machen ihm zu schaffen.
Ich halte in letzter Zeit
einfach nicht so viel aus.
Ja.
Es wäre wohl ...
... am besten,
wenn man jemanden zum Reden hätte.
Diese Situation
mit dem ganzen Drum und Dran ...
Du hast ja Silvia zum Reden.
Das ...- Manchmal wäre es besser,
noch eine andere Person zu haben.
Ja.
Fehlt die im Moment?
- Ein bisschen schon. Ja.
Kommst du ein bisschen zu Mami?
Ja. Ja, grüezi.
Ja, grüezi.
- Luisa, kommst du zu Daddy?
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich lege dich wieder auf die Seite.
Die drückende Hitze
dieses Sommertages
kostet die Familie Epp
manchen Schweisstropfen.
Der Wintervorrat für die Tiere
muss in den Stall gebracht werden.
Marianne
ist inzwischen diplomierte Bäuerin.
Sie hat die Bauernschule
mit Bestnoten abgeschlossen.
Auch die inzwischen elfjährige Julia
packt mit an.
Gefällt dir die Landwirtschaft
oder möchtest du was anderes machen?
Etwas anderes, glaube ich.
Landwirtschaft - ich weiss nicht.
Als Hobby wäre das wohl schon gut,
aber beruflich
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Sepp bedient den Kreisler.
Wegen
seiner angeschlagenen Gesundheit
muss er die schweren Arbeiten
seinen Kindern überlassen.
Es kackt manchmal schon an,
wenn man Wochenende machen will,
aber dann hier helfen kommt.
Ich kann nicht dabei zuschauen,
wie Daddy und Marianne
sich kaputtarbeiten,
während ich nichts mache.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn ich nicht helfe,
und Angst um sie,
weil sie so viel arbeiten.
Nur weil die Jungen mit anpacken,
kann der Bergbauer
seinen Betrieb noch aufrechterhalten.
Brutal gesagt: Wäre es nicht besser,
wenn er aufhören würde?
Er soll doch seine Jahre geniessen,
ohne immer zu arbeiten.
Ich sage mal,
dass es sicher schlau wäre.
Aber wenn Daddy
dann nicht mehr glücklich ist
und dann so leidet
und gar nichts mehr machen kann,
ist es eben auch nicht gut.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Sanfte Musik *
Drei Monate ist es her,
seit die kleine Luisa im Spital war.
Jetzt lebt die kleine Familie
wieder vereint
auf dem Hof im luzernischen Ruswil.
Wie geht es Luisa im Moment?
Wieder ziemlich gut.
Es sollte bald vorüber sein.
Die 100 Tage, die der Keuchhusten
dauert, sind bald durch.
Ja, es geht ihr eigentlich gut.
Sie ist einfach klein und zart,
aber ja ...
Doch von einem unbeschwerten Leben
kann keine Rede sein.
Der Betrieb ist hoch verschuldet.
Stefan musste Konkurs anmelden.
Macht man sich da Vorwürfe?
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, das macht niemand gerne.
Konkurs. Ja ...
Gibt es keine Möglichkeit,
damit es hier weitergeht?
Nein, in der momentanen Lage nicht.
Wie hoch verschuldet seid ihr denn?
Ja, so gegen 250'000 Fr.
schätze ich mal.
Das ist viel Geld.
Ziemlich viel.
- Belastet dich das stark?
Sehr, ja.
Ich hatte
ein paar schlaflose Nächte deswegen.
250'000 Fr. Schulden.
Dazu Luisas Krankheit
nach ihrer Geburt.
Silvia kann wegen ihrer Hüftprobleme
nicht zurück in ihren Beruf
als Pflegefachfrau.
Lange Zeit sagte er ihr nichts
über seine finanziellen Probleme.
Beiden fehlt eine Perspektive.
Er ist schwermütig
und sie enttäuscht.
Du hättest besser darauf achten
und mehr arbeiten können,
dir mehr Hilfe holen ...
... die Buchhaltung
besser anschauen ...
Ich hätte schon Dinge
anders machen können.
Wenn man es genau nimmt ...
So wie du mit 22 angefangen hast ...
Du hattest fast
keine Unterstützung ... Also, ja ...
Irgendwie ... Es hat fast ... Ja ...
Hätte ich dich vorher gekannt,
hätte ich dir das sagen können.
Du kannst das so einfach sagen.
Ich weiss,
dass es nicht einfach ist.
Wir versuchen jetzt, das Beste
aus der Situation zu machen.
Wir lassen los und gehen weiter.
Wenn Silvia
wenigstens eine Stelle hätte,
könnte sie die finanzielle Situation
etwas verbessern.
Die 24-Jährige sucht sich Hilfe
bei Esther Hofstetter von Procap.
Die Organisation hilft u.a.
Menschen mit Beeinträchtigungen
bei der Umschulung.
Lange kann Silvia
nicht auf den Beinen stehen.
Eine Arbeit im Sitzen
wäre ideal für sie.
Sie sind Fachfrau Betreuung?
- Ja.
Es ist auch bei der IV klar,
dass das nicht mehr geht.
Die IV geht ja davon aus,
dass eine leichte Tätigkeit
mit viel Sitzen möglich ist.
Ja.
- Jetzt geht es darum, was das wäre.
Das KV steht immer etwas im Raum.
Damit kann ich mich irgendwie
einfach nicht anfreunden.
Das KV ist sicher die letzte Option.
Alles andere vorher.
Sozialpädagogin
war mal noch angedacht,
aber von der Belastung her
ist das auch schwierig.
Aber vielleicht
könnte man das mal probieren.
Ja.
Das KV entspricht mir einfach nicht.
Silvia fühlt sich eng mit den Tieren
und der Landwirtschaft verbunden.
Am liebsten
würde sie Bäuerin bleiben.
Marcel Epp hat grosse Pläne: Er baut
sich in Altdorf ein Geschäft auf.
Das wird dann mein Büro.
Damit ich mich mit den Kunden
hinsetzen, einen Kaffee trinken
und alles
auf dem Computer anschauen kann.
Dafür habe ich den Container.
Damit man im Trockenen ist.
Wir sind ja
in einem Gebiet mit viel Föhn.
Wenn es windet, dann richtig.
Es ist nicht angenehm,
dann draussen etwas zu besprechen.
Hier können wir uns setzen.
Marcel
vermietet und verkauft Anhänger.
Transport & Handel
nennt er seine Firma.
Weil sein Unternehmen
noch in den Startlöchern steckt,
arbeitet er auch noch
als Lastwagenchauffeur.
Woher kommen die paar Anhänger?
Alle, die jetzt hier sind,
wurden aus Polen importiert.
Ich ging mal nach Polen,
1 Std. vor der russischen Grenze ...
... wir schauten uns das an, assen
etwas und ich wollte es versuchen.
Es hat alles funktioniert.
Das ist eine saubere Sache.
Damit kann man zufrieden sein.
Das habe ich alles
selber finanziert.
Sprich,
mein Sparkonto musste daran glauben.
Aber jeder, der mit etwas anfängt,
geht irgendwann ein Risiko ein.
Bei dem einem zahlt es sich aus,
bei dem anderen weniger.
Hast du schon einen verkauft?
Einen konnte ich schon verkaufen.
Der hier ist eine Occasion.
Ich kaufte ihn und in den nächsten
Tagen muss er zur Kontrolle.
Dafür hätte ich auch einen Käufer.
Daher ... Auch die Vermietung:
Den kann ich ein paarmal vermieten
in den nächsten Tagen.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Es hat gut angefangen.
Du wurdest
ein richtiger Businessmann.
Ich hoffe, dass ich das werde.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Unruhige Musik *
Die Situation wurde nicht besser
bei Silvia und Stefan Epp.
Der Konkurs des Hofes
oberhalb von Ruswil
löste eine Depression bei ihm aus.
Mehrere Wochen
verbrachte der 27-Jährige
in einer psychiatrischen Klinik.
Vor wenigen Tagen
kehrte er zu seiner Familie zurück.
Es ist wirklich toll von dir, dass
ihr in den letzten sechs Wochen,
in denen ich in St. Urban war,
den Betrieb so gut gemanagt habt.
Das schätze ich sehr
und bin euch sehr dankbar.
Ich habe Fehler gemacht,
drei, vier, fünf Jahre zurück.
Es wäre besser gewesen,
wenn du mir früher gesagt hättest,
dass du solche Schulden hast.
- Ich hatte halt Angst ...
... dich zu verlieren.
Ich finde,
die sechs Wochen taten ihm gut.
Er kann besser kommunizieren.
Er
ist etwas ruhiger und entspannter.
Und auch motivierter
bei gewissen Dingen.
Ja.
So.
Dann gehe ich. Ist gut? Tschüss.
- Ja. Tschüss. Mach es gut.
Schönen Tag.
- Ja, schön ...
Ja ...
- Wie man es nimmt.
Stefan muss sich aber noch schonen
und unnötige Belastungen vermeiden.
So lässt er Silvia
an diesem Tag alleine ziehen.
Sie geht
an die Versteigerung der Kühe.
Der Anlass findet
im luzernischen Gunzwil statt.
(Ansage) Katalog Nummer 64.
Wir kommen zum nächsten Rind,
Katalog Nummer 8.
Alle 20 Milchkühe von Stefan
und Silvia werden versteigert.
Vom Erlös sehen die beiden nichts.
Er fliesst vollumfänglich
in die Konkursmasse ein.
Ist das eine?
- Das ist meine.
(Ansage) Diese Tiere sind alle aus
dem Bestand Epp, Stefan und Silvia.
Wir fangen mit 2'000 Fr. an.
Wo hat es zum Start 2'000 Fr.?
2'000 Fr.? 2'000 Fr.? 2'000 Fr.?
21, 121, 122, 122, 122,
123.50, 23.50, 23.50 ...
24 und wir spotten.
und wir spotten eine herrliche Kuh.
27 und wir spotten ...
27 und wir spotten zum Ersten ...
27.50, 27.50, 28, 128, 128, 128.
28.50 ist geboten. Zum Ersten ...
... zum Zweiten und zum Dritten.
Glückwunsch, Katalog Nummer 41.
28.50.
Das ist gut.
Es tat schon enorm weh.
Das ist klar.
Das ist schon endgültig.
Ja.
Der ganze Viehbestand
konnte vermarktet werden.
Nun heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Das Ende
eines weiteren Bauernbetriebs.
Komm, Patty. Hm?
Hast du eine enge Beziehung zu ihr?
- Ja, das war meine.
Bis vor ein paar Minuten.
Du hörst schon zu, nicht?
Ja, sie ist eine Tolle.
Hm? Sie geht bis nach Basel.
* Emotionale Klaviermusik *
* Entspannte Musik *
Im Acherli
nimmt alles seinen gewohnten Lauf.
Sepps Körper sagt ihm schon lange,
dass er kürzertreten muss.
Aber noch
hat er keine Lösung gefunden,
um das Bauerngut zu retten.
Deshalb macht er weiter,
trotz versteiften Sprunggelenken
und Prothesen.
Kannst du noch gut
an so einem steilen Teil arbeiten?
Nein, gut wäre anders.
Aber ich arbeite
ab und zu ein bisschen.
Ich mache, was möglich ist.
Aber nein, nein ...
... ich habe schon Mühe.
Mit seinem eigenen Schicksal
kann er gut umgehen.
Was ihn aber bekümmert,
sind Silvias und Stefans Probleme.
Das beschäftigt mich
eigentlich mehr ...
... als wenn ich
jetzt aufhören müsste.
Wenn eines der Jungen solche
Probleme hat, ist das nicht schön.
Ja.
Ich denke oft darüber nach ...
... was ich da machen könnte.
Oder ja ...
Aber man kann nicht helfen
bzw. es ist nicht gut zu helfen.
Doch insgeheim
hat sich der 66-Jährige
bereits eine Lösung ausgedacht.
Eine,
die auch ihm entgegenkommen würde.
Schon lange möchte Sepp
seinen Betrieb
an die nächste Generation übergeben.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
was mit Silvia passiert.
Darum will ich das
nicht einfach hinwerfen.
Vielleicht
könnten Silvia und ihr Mann ...
Ja ...
Wenn es sonst keine ...
Vielleicht haben sie eine Chance,
hier mit Ziegen oder Schafen
was zu machen.
Denkst du wirklich, Silvia und Stefan
würden hier Landwirtschaft betreiben?
Nein, das nicht.
Aber wenn sie
gar keine Arbeit und nichts haben,
wäre hier die Chance,
etwas zu machen.
Es ist doch wichtig,
dass man in seinem Leben arbeitet.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist still geworden, so ganz ohne
Tiere, im Gehöft oberhalb von Ruswil.
Doch statt Trübsinn,
herrscht Aufbruchstimmung.
Silvia und Stefan haben mit Sepp
über die Hofübernahme gesprochen.
Die beiden
wollen nun ins Acherli ziehen.
Was hat zu dem Sinneswandel geführt,
Silvia?
Ihr überlegt euch jetzt doch,
das Acherli zu übernehmen.
Ich denke,
der wichtigste Faktor ist sicher,
dass wir hier
keine Perspektiven haben.
Stefan hat einen Job gesucht
und nichts gefunden
und ich mache seit vier Jahren
Umschulungsmassnahmen mit der IV.
Es geht einfach nicht vorwärts.
Wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt,
wo wir eine andere Lösung brauchen.
Für mich ist es auch die Tatsache,
dass ich hier abgeschlossen habe.
Darum ist es auch einfacher,
den Entscheid zu treffen,
ins Acherli zu gehen
und es zu übernehmen.
Seid ihr glücklich mit dieser Lösung?
Ja, das sicher.
- Er wahrscheinlich mehr als ich.
Sein Traum war immer,
wieder irgendwo anzufangen.
Ich denke,
für dich ist das schon ...
Du hast Daddy und Unterstützung
und kannst davon ausgehen,
dass es funktioniert.
- Auf jeden Fall.
Für mich ist es ...
Das dort oben ...
Das sind meine Wurzeln.
Ich mochte den Hof, die Tiere
und alles dort oben immer.
Eine andere Lösung wäre für mich
aber auch okay gewesen.
Aber man
freundet sich mit dem Gedanken an.
Jetzt versuchen wir es.
Eine Hürde muss noch genommen werden:
Silvias Geschwister müssen mit
der Hofübernahme einverstanden sein.
Marianne Epp hat seit
ein paar Monaten eine neue Stelle.
Wir sind heute zusammengekommen,
um zu besprechen,
was man mit der Wildkarte
machen könnte -
um Ideen zu sammeln.
Die 29-Jährige arbeitet in Schwyz
als Kaderfrau in einem Restaurant.
Sie führt 13 Mitarbeitende.
Diese mussten sich zuerst
an den frischen Wind gewöhnen,
den sie in den Betrieb brachte.
Es war eine turbulente Zeit,
seit ich hier bin.
Es war schwierig, die
neuen Strukturen zu implementieren.
Aber mittlerweile
sind wir auf einem guten Weg
und setzen das gut um mit dem Team.
Stets zögerte sie, den Betrieb
ihres Vaters zu übernehmen.
Dass nun Silvia und Stefan
ins Acherli einziehen möchten,
findet die gelernte Bäuerin
keine gute Lösung.
Die beiden seien nicht in der Lage,
den Hof erfolgreich zu führen,
glaubt Marianne.
Zudem befürchtet sie,
ihre Heimat zu verlieren.
Das Acherli war immer
der sicherste Ort für mich -
in Anführungs- und Schlusszeichen.
Sollte alles bachab gehen-
sei das im Geschäft oder im Leben -,
wusste ich immer,
dass ich ins Acherli zurückkönnte.
Das Acherli
war immer ein sicherer Ort.
Wie das halt ist,
wenn man Familie hat.
Wenn das bachab geht,
habe ich dann das Gefühl,
es fehle mir ein Stück.
Ich glaube ... Ja ...
* Ruhige Musik *
Im Acherli kommt es Anfang Dezember
zu einer Aussprache.
Die Familie
bespricht die Zukunft des Hofes.
Es ist schön ...
... dass wir
wieder mal zusammensitzen.
Wir wissen,
dass es eine Veränderung geben muss.
Vielleicht können wir wirklich
zusammen eine Lösung finden.
Daddy hat das hier aufgebaut.
Er hat
viele Stunden und Jahre gearbeitet.
Es ist schade, wenn wir das
zugrunde gehen lassen ...
... wenn wir es
eigentlich erhalten könnten.
Es gibt keine Garantie,
dass das funktioniert.
Es gibt keine Garantie für nichts.
Aus meiner Sicht ...
Ich habe in den vier Jahren
auch die Buchhaltung gesehen.
Ich habe schon gesagt,
dass es schwierig ist,
mit den Einnahmen
der Direktzahlungen dieses Betriebs
eine Familie durchzubringen.
(Silvia) Reich werden wir hier nie,
das ist uns bewusst.
Aber davon leben könnten wir.
(Marianne)
Reich werdet ihr sicher nicht.
Die Buchhaltung
ist ein Nullsummenspiel.
(Silvia) Man kann es
auch zu pessimistisch sehen.
Ich bin nicht pessimistisch.
Ich weiss,
wie die Buchhaltung aussieht.
Seht sie euch an
und entscheidet dann.
Marianne, du redest, als wärst du
der Oberprofi und wüsstest alles.
Ich meine, ich sah das auch
ein bisschen in den letzten Jahren.
Also ...
- Ich bin einfach der Ansicht ...
Ja, wir müssen uns das
sicher genau anschauen.
Ich will ja nicht ...
Du hast das bei euch gesehen,
aber nicht bei uns.
Ich habe mit Daddy auch
ab und zu was angeschaut. Nicht?
Ja ...
- Mhm. Ja dann ...
Bevor man alles zusammenstreicht,
Land verpachtet
und einen Hobbybetrieb
daraus macht ...
Das ist halbwegs eine Existenz.
Das andere ist nichts.
Gar nichts.
- Doch, man hat ja doch noch ...
Man kann ja immer noch Tiere haben,
um noch etwas zu haben.
Das hat nichts mehr
mit Landwirtschaft zu tun.
Nein, das ist so,
als hätte man Zwerghasen.
Das geht in die Richtung.
(Tamara) Wo ich schwarzsehe,
ist beim Heuen.
Wie oft waren wir zu dritt
bis abends um 19.30 Uhr dran ...
Meistens wart ihr nicht hier.
Mal kamt ihr, dann wieder nicht.
Klar brauchen wir Hilfe
beim Heuen und allem.
Aber es gibt sicher Leute, die
hinter uns stehen und uns helfen.
Niemand sagt,
wir würden nicht hinter euch stehen.
Aber wenn man es abgeben und alle
ihren eigenen Weg gehen könnten ...
Ich habe Daddy gerne geholfen
und würde es wieder machen.
Aber schlussendlich
ist es dann euer Hof.
Ihr müsst schauen,
dass ihr irgendwie zurechtkommt.
(Tamara) Ich hoffe,
ihr seid uns nicht böse,
wenn wir
nicht mehr so oft hier sind.
Es ist dann nicht mehr
unser Zuhause, sondern eures.
Ich will einfach,
dass wir friedlich auseinandergehen.
Es ist verdammt schade,
wenn sich dann alle blöd anmachen,
weil es jetzt halt so ist.
Alle sind willkommen bei uns. Ja.
Egal, wie oft ihr vorbeikommt.
Es ist euch überlassen ...
... wie oft ihr kommen wollt,
aber die Tür ist offen.
Das möchte ich einfach sagen.
Ich hoffe, dass niemand von euch
wütend hier weggeht und sagt ...
... dass man das
nicht so machen sollte oder dürfte.
Also ich ... ich ...
Ich gebe ihnen diese Chance gerne.
Eben ...
Ich denke,
dass das keine schlechte Lösung ist.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Es ist ein frostiger Tag -
und doch voller Hoffnung.
Sepps Nachfolger ziehen in den
kleinen Hof oberhalb von Bristen ein.
Silvia und Stefan Epp sind die fünfte
Generation im Familienbetrieb.
Damit ihr wisst, wo alles hinkommt:
Küchentisch, Stube, Waschküche.
Stube.
Gut?
Nur Marcel
hilft den beiden beim Einzug.
Alle anderen Geschwister
zeigen sich an diesem Tag nicht.
Sie glauben, dass Silvia und Stefan
die neue Aufgabe unterschätzen.
Das glaube ich eher nicht.
Ich bin ja hier aufgewachsen.
Ich weiss, was es bedeutet,
hier Landwirtschaft zu betreiben.
Ich bin sicher,
wenn man es gut organisiert,
kann man hier eine Existenz haben.
Daddy hat auch vier Kinder
hier grossgezogen.
Bist du zufrieden mit der Lösung,
dass Silvia und Stefan übernehmen?
Ja, also ...
Für mich ist wichtig,
dass es eine Lösung gab.
Also ...
Sie müssen jetzt selber schauen.
Das geht schon.
Stets ging die Familie
gemeinsam durch dick und dünn.
Nun ist sie gespalten.
V.a. Marianne ist verärgert.
Ja, das ist schon schade.
Ja.
Ist das eine Belastung?
Es ist wirklich ... Ja, ja.
Es ist eine Belastung. Aber ...
Man kann es nicht beeinflussen.
- Wir brauchten eine Entscheidung.
Sie hat natürlich
wirklich Herzblut reingesteckt.
Ja, aber sie
konnte sich nicht dafür entscheiden.
100%ig.
Sie kann mir
jetzt nicht den Vorwurf machen,
dass sie
sich nicht entscheiden konnte.
Sie hatte die Fäden in der Hand.
Sie hätte es übernehmen können.
Dann wäre es klar gewesen und ich
hätte ihr keinen Vorwurf gemacht.
Es ist wirklich nicht so einfach.
Wenn man den Kindern am Ende nicht
mehr in die Augen sehen darf ...
... wenn sie kommen ...
Das ... Ja, es ist schade.
Das ist es. Aber ...
Ich hoffe,
das beruhigt sich alles wieder.
Ich glaube,
wir nehmen zuerst den Tisch raus.
Sepp wird mit seiner Lebenspartnerin
Maria und Tochter Julia
nach Bristen ziehen.
Etwas drehen. Etwas drehen. Gut.
Alle alten Möbel müssen raus.
Auch der Küchentisch.
Um ihn herum versammelte sich
jahrzehntelang die Familie.
Um den Tisch tut es mir leid.
Das war ein guter.
Aber ...
Ja ...
Bei der Ware ist es wie bei uns:
Die alte muss raus
und die neue kommt rein.
Ist es ein schwieriger Moment?
Ja ...
Ich hatte schon viele schwierige
Momente im Acherli.
Ja ... Doch, das wird schon gut.
Positiv denken,
dann wird das schon gut.
Und so endet diese Geschichte
mit einem Neuanfang.
Viele Jahre lang hat Familie Epp
um eine Lösung gerungen.
Jetzt ist sie da.
Aber der Schatten über dem Acherli
bleibt.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021